>> Katie: WELL, THE LEFT
ANTIGUN AGENDA SCORED A MAJOR
VICTORY IN AFTERMATH OF THE
LATEST MASS SHOOTING.
DEERFIELD, MANUFACTURER OF
CHICAGO, HAVE BANNED LARGE
CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
THE RESIDENTS HAVE UNTIL JUNE
13 TO GIVE THEM UP.
IF THEY REFUSE THEY WILL FACE
FINES UP TO $1,000 PER DAY.
WILL OTHER LIBERAL STRONGHOLDS
TRY TO FOLLOW IN THE PATH?
JOINING US WITH REACTION
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST JOEL
PAYNE.
JOEL, WE HAVE BEEN HEARING FOR
WEEKS THAT THE LEFT DOESN'T
HAVE AN ANTIGUN AGENDA, THEY
DON'T HAVE AN AGENDA OF
BANNING GUNS.
BUT YET, HERE WE ARE WITH
DEERFIELD, ILLINOIS, NOT JUST
BANNING ASSAULT RIFLES WHICH
IS A LOADED POLITICAL TERM.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
SEMI-AUTOMATIC SPORTING RIFLES
HERE.
BUT A NUMBER OF OTHER
ACCESSORIES THAT THEY DEEM AS
MILITARY STYLE.
>> I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE
LEFT DOING THIS.
THIS IS A LOCALITY COMING
TOGETHER TO DO SOMETHING FOR
THE SAFETY OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
THE SAME AS ANOTHER COMMUNITY
DID VERY NEAR DEERFIELD,
HIGHLAND PARK, I BELIEVE, IN
2013.
THEY ACTUALLY SURVIVED A
COUPLE OF LEGAL CHALLENGES
THAT SHOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT THE COURT DID NOT STAND
IN THE WAY OF.
IT FOLLOWS SUIT WITH WHAT
FLORIDA DID AFTER THE PARKLAND
SHOOTING.
LOCALITIES COMING TOGETHER
BECAUSE THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT, THE NATIONAL
LEADERS FAILED TO ACT
MEANINGFULLY ON GUN CONTROL,
ON ENSURING WE ARE PROTECTING
THE CITIZEN FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
>> Katie: NOT EVERYONE WAS
ON BOARD.
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE AT THE
MEETING SAID THEY WERE AGAINST
THE MEASURE.
I WANT TO PLAY SOUND FROM A
WOMAN AT THE MEETING AGAINST
BANNING THE TYPE OF FIREARMS.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS BUT I'D BE HARD-PRESSED
TO FIND ANY RIGHT THAT IS
COMPLETELY UNRESTRICTED.
>> Katie: SORRY.
SHE IS FOR THE MEASURE.
HOW DOES ILLINOIS NOT HAVE A
NUMBER OF LEGISLATION AND
REGULATIONS ON THE BOOK
ALREADY WHEN IT COMES TO GUN
CONTROL?
>> LOCALITIES HAVE THE RIGHT
TO ACT AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE
PROTECTING THE CITIZENS.